up a little bit 62-year-old bobby
burdette has just emerged from the covid
intensive care unit at our lady of the
lake hospital in baton rouge louisiana
staff have nicknamed him their miracle
patient most haven't been leaving the
icu alive i feel really well
my breathing has really gotten under
control
burdette was never vaccinated and says
he still has no regrets his wife also
tested positive
they're part of a dramatic surge in
covet cases in louisiana only 39 percent
of the state is fully vaccinated that's
strictly an individual decision it ain't
the governments it ain't anybody else
but theirs according to the louisiana
health department the unvaccinated make
up more than 90 percent of hospitalized
coveted patients ready one two three
nurse lori douglas has been caring for
them many of whom are young and
otherwise healthy she says most do tell
her they wish they'd gotten the vaccine
it's to know that this was preventable
and that this didn't need to happen
and that
you know there is a girl who without her
mother
anymore that a man doesn't have his
brother any longer his big brother to
turn to in times like that it's
heart-wrenching with covet patients
filling hospital beds major hospitals in
louisiana are no longer accepting
transfers emergency rooms are seeing
weights of up to 10 hours and patients
with other emergency conditions even
heart attacks have sometimes been turned
away
we're already rationing care and every
day we continue to admit the same amount
of people if not more so we'll get to a
point soon where it's we're unable to
patch it together a federal disaster
team is working with the state's
hospitals to relieve the strain but
doctors say what they also need are more
people getting the vaccine a recent
uptick in vaccinations is promising but
not enough every person who comes into
the hospital and is not vaccinated is a
failure on our part it is our job as
medical professionals to educate people
and we haven't gotten our education out
and in the absence of that there's
misinformation
misinformation distrust in government
and misplaced confidence are all hurdles
to getting the vaccine among louisiana's
fiercely independent population
as for burdette and his wife even a
near-death experience in the hospital
hasn't convinced them to get the shots
for now they'll focus on recovery get
well
eventually get to where my immune system
is up to where i can start seeing people
and hug the heck of my grandkids
time left with family a gift denied to
some 700 people a day who continue to
die of kovid in the u.s
heidi joe castro al jazeera baton rouge
louisiana